We touched on this in the video
on resonance, but I want
to devote an entire video
to aromatic compounds.
And one of the big mysteries in
chemistry is why they were
named aromatic compounds.
Because you know it clearly
comes from the word aroma.
So one would think maybe all of
these compounds smell good,
or smell bad, or don't
smell at all.
But actually it turns out
that a lot of them don't
even smell at all.
So it's a little bit
of a mystery.
Some people think that they
have some relation, the
gentleman who named them, saw
that they had some chemical
relation to things that did
smell, so that he named them
aromatic compounds.
So it is a bit of a mystery.
In general, the most common
aromatic compound-- and really
this is like 99% of the time
what you're going to see in
chemistry class as an aromatic
compound-- is either benzene
or a molecule derived
from benzene.
Let me draw benzene
right here.
So benzene is normally
drawn like this.
So it's a six carbon ring.
And it has three double bonds.
It has three double
bonds like that.
And we learned in the resonance
video, that this
isn't actually the only
configuration for benzene.
It could just as likely be
in this configuration.
That this electron up here, this
electron up here, might
move there.
This electron might
move over there.
And then this electron might
Let me clear that up, so you
don't make it too confusing.
So it could just as likely
be in this configuration.
It could just as likely be in
this configuration right here,
where the double bonds are on
the other bonds that aren't
double bonded over here.
So it could just as easily
be over there.
And we learned in the resonance
video that the
reality is that it's actually
in between.
And sometimes it's
drawn like this.
It's going back and forth
between these configurations.
But the reality-- and
you'll sometimes see
it drawn like this.
You'll sometimes see it drawn
like this, with just a circle
in between, in the middle of the
hexane ring, I guess you
could say, or the
benzene ring.
Which is showing that the
electrons, those pi electrons,
those electrons that form the
double bond are actually just,
they're going back and
forth between this.
They're just spreading around
the entire ring.
And what makes aromatic
compounds interesting is
because these pi electrons can
spread around the entire ring,
it's actually a much more stable
configuration, or a
much more stable molecule, than
what you would predict if
you just looked at one of these
two configurations.
Another way that it's
often drawn looks
something like this.
And I'm just doing it in yellow,
just to have something
in a different color.
Sometimes you'll just see
this, that you know, is
someplace in between
that and that.
So you'll have a dotted line
there, dotted line, dotted
line, dotted line, dotted
line, dotted line.
This is the most common kind of
short hand for showing both
benzene and for showing that
it's experiencing this
resonance, that you have
this conjugated
system of pi electrons.
And I'll help you visualize
that in a second.
But you also might see
something like this.
It can go back and forth, and
everything in between, between
these two configurations.
Now just to visualize
what's going on.
Because you'll sometimes hear
people talk about conjugated
system of pi electrons.
I want to actually think about,
help a little bit more
visualizing what the molecule
might look like in three
dimensions.
So that is the six carbon
ring right there.
So it's carbon, carbon, carbon,
carbon, carbon, carbon.
And then each of these carbons
is bonded to three other
atoms. It's bonded
to 1, 2 carbons.
And it's also bonded
to a hydrogen.
So let me draw the
hydrogens here.
They're also bonded
to hydrogen.
So this one will have a
hydrogen over here.
This will have a hydrogen
over here.
That will have a hydrogen
over there.
That one has a hydrogen
Hydrogen and hydrogen
right over there.
So if we talk about
hybridization, we have three
hybridized orbitals.
This is sp2 hybridization.
And each of these have a
leftover pi orbital that has
not been hybridized.
It's not directly bound to, or
that does not have a sigma
bond to another atom.
So you have these pi orbitals.
You know, these pi orbitals
look like these dumbbells.
So you have a pi orbital
over here.
You have a pi orbital here.
Pi orbital over here.
Pi orbital over there.
You have another pi orbital
over there.
Pi orbital and pi orbital.
And you know, pi orbital, I drew
them like this, because
if I drew them bigger
than that, the
diagram would get messy.
But in general, whenever you
have double bonds, like this
double bond.
Let's say that this carbon--
let me change colors, so we
know what we're focused on.
So let's say this sigma bond
right over there, let's say
that sigma bond right over
there, is this sigma bond.
Actually let me do another
one, just so
it's easier to see.
Let's say that this sigma bond
right over here is this sigma
bond, between these
two carbons.
This double bond, the double
bond in blue, this one, or in
purple right over there,
that's due to these
overlapping pi orbitals.
That carbon's pi orbitals and
that carbon's pi orbitals
overlapping.
I haven't drawn them
overlapping, but-- well,
actually an electron
can really show up.
It's all probabilistic anyway.
But I could draw them big
enough, they would overlap,
and these electrons would
form that extra pi bond.
What happens in a conjugated
system of pi electrons.
Let me write that down.
It's just a very fancy word.
Conjugated system
of pi electrons.
These guys, at we see,
they could be
bonded with each other.
These guys could overlap.
So there could be an overlap
going on over here.
Or we could flip into this
configuration, where this guy
would overlap with this
guy over here.
And the reality is that these pi
electrons will actually be
able to float around the ring.
They'd actually be able to float
around all of these pi
orbitals right over there.
They'd actually be able to
float around the ring.
So that's what people are really
talking about when they
talk about aromatic compounds,
or aromaticity.
That because of this, this is
a more stable compound.
The most typical one that you're
going to see is a six
carbon chain with three double
bonds, benzene, or things
derived from them.
But there actually are
more general ones.
In general, you're going to see
anything that has 4n plus
2 pi electrons in a cycle is
going to have aromaticity.
Or is going to be an
aromatic compound.
Let's just confirm this
actually makes it.
Each of these guys over here
have one pi electron, even
though this looks
like two bonds.
Remember, this is one pi orbital
right over here.
And you have one electron that's
going to be in this
entire pi orbital.
So this has one pi electron,
two, three, four, five, six.
Another way to think about it,
each of these double bonds
involves two pi electrons.
So one, two, three,
four, five, six.
So that follows what is
called Huckel's rule.
I think there's two
dots above the u.
Huckel's rule, maybe.
That follows Huckel's rule.
Because if you said n is
equal to 1, 4 times 1
is 4 plus 2 is 6.
So 6 pi electrons work.
If n was 2, you'd have 4 times
2 plus 2, which is 10.
So if you had 10 pi electrons,
it would also work.
So a molecule that looks
like this-- let me see
if I can draw it.
A molecule that looks like
this would also work.
So if you have one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine, ten, ten carbons.
And then you had five
double bonds.
So, one, two, three,
four, five.
Just like that.
You could imagine, these
guys could flip around.
But this would also be
an aromatic compound.
This has 10 pi electrons.
Each of the carbons have
a pi electron.
Or you could count the
pi electrons on each
end of these pi bonds.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
Now this is one thing that
I always wonder.
It's like OK, it worked
with six.
It worked with 10.
But what about eight?
It seems like with eight, maybe
these electrons, these
double bonds, could flip
around just as easily.
So what if I had, what if
I had-- or even four.
What if I had a molecule
that looked like this?
Or a molecule that looked like
a stop sign-- so one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven,
eight-- that had double bonds
that alternated like this.
You might say, hey,
maybe those also
are aromatic compounds.
Those also experience
aromaticity.
Because couldn't this guy jump
around here, then that guy
over there, and the electrons
cycle around.
Or this guy jump over, these
electrons move there.
Those move there.
And those move there.
And it turns out that in these
compounds, the electrons do
not, the pi electrons do not
stabilize the system.
But this is actually less
stable than if it
was not in a cycle.
So actually this is-- these
right here, that don't follow
the 4n plus 2.
So 4n plus 2, you're talking
about 6, 10, 14 pi electrons.
Which usually means
14 carbons, or 10
carbons, or six carbons.
The ones that don't follow them
but are still cyclical,
and still have these alternating
bonds, these are
called anti-aromatic.
And are actually
very unstable.
These are very, very unstable
and are more likely to break
into a non-cycle.
Anyway, hopefully you found
that vaguely useful.